if sharing is caring then a handful of
states are betting that the sharing of
salary details is a step towards evening
the playing field among workers
right now the data highlights a
persistent wage gap across gender and
race
white women who work full-time take home
83 cents for every dollar that men earn
for some women of color the gap is wider
71 cents for black women and 64 cents
for hispanic women
so what are states doing colorado is
leading the way it's 2021 pay
transparency law requires employers to
publish the salary range and benefits
for new job listings
at least six other states have similar
laws on their books while new york city
is the first city to move on this
at the same time states and cities are
making what used to be normal practices
illegal like employers asking job
candidates for their salary history and
punishing workers who decide to share
their pay information with others
companies are pushing back against this
shift to pay transparency one of their
arguments is that pay bans are often too
broad to be useful i think the important
piece is going to be really
digging into the demographics right how
do you disaggregate the data
within those bands and really look at
trends like really looking at the equity
implications of that so i think
starting even with general bands is a
step in the right direction they also
say it's bad timing because of how hard
it is to find workers right now and so
they need flexibility on pay
especially if their current staff is
paid less than the going rate
existing workers may leave if they don't
get a raise compounding the labor
shortage and adding to costs at a time
when companies are already trying to
manage rising inflation of course
workers too are facing inflation in
their everyday expenses as well
the other downside for employers sharing
pay details opens them up to legal risks
here's how
federal law prohibits them from fixing
wages but local paid transparency laws
may reveal the extent to which employers
sometimes share pay information with
each other even if they never actually
agreed to set wages
that could lead uncle sam to conclude
that a company violated anti-trust laws
no matter the efforts to reform pay and
equity there is one thing that is
outside the purview of the law
most women don't negotiate their pay
one survey finds 57 percent of women say
they never haggled over their salary
versus 51 percent of men
more data goes a long way but you don't
get what you don't ask for
[Music]